-Our first guest tonight
is an Emmy, a Tony,
and Golden Globe-winning actor
you know from shows
like "Cheers" and "Frasier."
He stars in the film
"Like Father,"
which is streaming on Netflix.
Let's take a look.
-How'd you guys meet?
-Yeah, what's your story?
-How'd you catch the silver fox?
-Ooh.
-[ Sighs ]
-Hi.
I'm Harry, actually --
Rachel's dad.
Rachel and Owen decided
not to get married,
so she invited me to come.
You see, I left her
when she was 5 years old.
It's unforgivable.
I know.
So I showed up at their wedding
a few days ago,
and that's when Owen decided
to be a little bitch
and leave Rachel at the altar.
So I took Rachel out
and got her good and drunk
and, uh, we're here.
-Please welcome back
to the show
Kelsey Grammer, everyone.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
Welcome back.
-Thank you, Seth.
-I'm so happy to have you here.
I want to say this,
and I mean this genuinely.
I've been doing this show
for a while now.
There's never been a better clip
to explain the movie
than the clip we just showed.
-That's pretty much it.
That's the movie in a nutshell.
-Not only was it really funny,
but it let you know
who the actors were,
and your character basically
explained the plot.
-Exactly what's going to happen.
That's exactly it.
And the movie is very,
very heartwarming and heartfelt
and very emotional in places.
There's kind of
an undercurrent story
about Alzheimer's in it,
which is not particularly funny,
of course,
but it gives it
a kind of gravitas
and an emotional foundation
that's actually --
it's a great movie.
-It's really fun.
I know a ton of people are
watching it already, which is --
-It's a big hit apparently.
-That's very exciting.
You actually --
So you shot on a cruise ship.
-Mm-hmm.
-We had Seth Rogen here
this week talking about that.
But I didn't realize
there was a hurricane
in the lead up
to getting onto the ship.
-Right.
Hurricane Irma was sort of
playing tag with us
the whole time.
And so the first week
of the cruise was cut in half
because the ship
wouldn't leave the dock.
Oh, no, it had to go out
into the middle of the sea
and dodge the hurricane...
-I see.
So that's probably safer --
-...without passengers.
-Right.
-Apparently, it is.
You know, hurricanes are not
such a big deal at sea.
-Right.
-They're more of a problem
when they hit land.
-Right, as a giant boat,
you don't want
to be right next to land.
-You sure don't because then
it ends up on the land.
-Right. Yeah.
-That sort of thing.
-[ Chuckles ]
-Tilted.
But it was a fun experience.
I've always lived on boats
myself.
I grew up on boats.
I used to own a boat.
It's one of the great passions
of my life, so --
-What -- I always am curious
when people own boats.
What was the name of your boat?
-Oh, this is --
this has been the subject
of some ridicule in the past.
-Oh. Well, I apologize
in advance for asking.
-It's okay.
My boat,
my first boat
that I actually bought myself,
I didn't buy it
until I was about 32 years old.
It had been my dream
ever since I was a young man.
And I finally got enough money
to buy this sailboat,
a 37-foot Baltic sloop.
And I could single-hand it.
I practically lived on it
for a few years.
But in order to remind myself
that I shouldn't take myself
too seriously,
it was called The BIOYAK,
which is an acronym for
"Blow it out your ass, Kels."
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
That's great.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I think that's really nice.
Because I feel like
a lot of other people,
when they get their boats, they
name it the other direction.
They -- Like "The Winner."
-Well -- [ Laughing ]
No, no.
I think that's pretentious
and horrible.
-Well, that's nice.
And do you still have
The BIOYAK?
-No, I had to sell it.
Now, this is a kind of
a remarkable situation.
I had just fallen in love
with Kayte, who is my wife now,
and we have three children
and we've been married
for almost eight years.
But I also spoke to her --
When we first met,
we lived in New York.
I was doing a play on Broadway,
and we spent
most of our time here.
The first opportunity we had
to go to California, I said,
"I've got to get you
on the boat.
You have to come down
to the boat,
and you're going to love it."
So I took her to the boat,
and she boarded the boat.
She's standing in the cockpit,
I throw open the hatch,
went down the ladder,
and I'm looking inside
down below decks.
And behind me
comes this voice that says,
"Have you ever had sex
on this boat?"
[ Laughter ]
[ Audience oohs ]
So I spent about probably
what felt like an eternity
was probably 30 seconds
trying to run through
every scenario
that would be convincing
that I hadn't had sex on a boat
I'd owned for 25 years.
So I thought, "Oh [bleep] I'm
just going to have to tell her."
Sorry.
[ Laughs ]
I turned around,
and I said, "Yes."
And she said, "Well,
then I'm not going out on it."
-Wow! She drew the line.
-Absolutely, so --
-So you had to sell the boat?
-I sold the boat.
-Did you get --
-I actually donated the boat.
-You donated it.
-To charity.
-Well, right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-But I thought
what she was saying was fair.
She said I could get
another boat if I wanted to,
but, you know.
-When you donated it
to the charity,
did you let them know how much
sex you'd had on it, or...?
-Uh, I did not.
-You did not.
-I gave it a good cleaning.
[ Laughter ]
-So I want to ask
because you actually
shot this
on a functional cruise ship.
-A functional cruise ship.
It's the largest ship
on the world.
And because
I'd run boats all my life,
when I met the captain
of the ship --
because it's called a ship.
You know, it's the largest thing
that moves made by man.
It's an extraordinary vessel.
And he is -- this Captain may be
out of a hundred guys
in the world
qualified to do this job.
-Sure.
-He is the king of it.
He sits at the pinnacle
of his trade.
And I thought, that is a truly
admirable quality.
And he's a terrific guy.
And he looks after 7,000 souls
on every trip.
It's an extraordinary thing.
-Did you get to go into --
is it a cockpit?
What do you call where he --
-Oh, no, I never --
The wheelhouse or the bridge.
I never went there.
But I did go below.
I went below decks
a few times to the kitchen,
which is as big as 30 Rock,
practically.
-[ Chuckling ] I can imagine.
-I mean, it's just unbelievable.
They serve something like
22,000 buns every morning.
-That's a lot of buns.
The last time
there were that many buns
was your old boat.
-Exactly.
[ Laughter ]
Just down on the old BIOYAK.
-The BIOYAK.
[ Applause ]
You also --
You shot inside a waterfall.
You have a scene
inside a waterfall.
-Well, it's like a big --
it's a waterfall in Jamaica.
Getting to it
was somewhat treacherous.
And it's funny,
I'm shooting a film right now
where there was some water stuff
we did, as well,
and the same guy
was my stunt double
on the film I'm doing now.
And so I asked him, I said,
"How dangerous was that jump?"
Because they wouldn't
let me do it.
I said, "I'll give it a shot."
And he said,
"I almost killed myself."
-Oh, wow.
-So, I thought,
"Okay, that's good."
[ Laughter ]
"It's better you almost
killed yourself than me."
But I did have other scenes
I had to shoot,
and he wouldn't have,
so if we'd lost him,
it would have been
a noble -- noble burial.
[ Laughter ]